ah okay great
well uh welcome to another episode of
science and technology q a for kids and
others
and i see there are a bunch of questions
saved up here
oh my
the question here
are
[Music]
from aaron
do i think that having
eventually lots of iot devices will
necessitate additional routing logic on
local networks
to prevent things like desktops from
being slow okay let's take that question
part it's kind of fun
um talk about a little bit
so first of all what is iot
it's a stands for internet of things i
think it kind of originated it was a
phrase originated about 10 years ago
and
the kind of the concept was at first
computer networks connect computers
and they kind of also connect phones
originally phones were connected just to
the
telephone network but then the telephone
network started transmitting data and
phones started connecting to wi-fi and
pretty soon a phone is just like a baby
computer um and uh it's the same kind of
story of connecting computers to
computers
through a network either a local network
or through the internet
um and phones
to
the same network basically
now the thing that became popular is
this idea of an internet of things
so
uh that is particularly
uh things with sensors actuators so for
example you know the the thermostat the
web the the uh the doorbell with the
camera
the uh uh the the device that measures
um you know i think people were very
keen or a number of years ago now the
plant that tweets
uh you know you have a plant
that um
uh has a humidity sensor or soil sensor
or something
and the plant will
if something is um if it if it needs to
be watered or something it will start
tweeting at you i have to say i wonder
in the modern question of the definition
of bots on twitter i wonder how many
plants there are that i have um
because it was a was a thing i think it
i really was popular maybe
eight ten years ago now um of people
talking about connecting
uh the ability to
send messages to things like twitter
from inanimate objects
objects like plants and so on
um
well so anyway this notion of internet
of things it's sort of a question of
what kinds of things can have sensors
associated with i mean i know
for years now i've had a toothbrush that
has a you know bluetooth connection that
uh sends data somewhere of um
and there are all these different things
that now have
uh um
sort of network connectivity i mean i
think one that has kind of gone in and
out of fashion is refrigerators
of the question of whether for example
you have the refrigerator with the
camera inside let's go figuring out when
do you need to get more milk or
something um or a variety of other kinds
of uh mechanisms like that um i think
you know toasters uh one that often are
raised as a as a sort of uh slightly
humorous example of things that do or
don't have kind of internet connectivity
now sometimes there are things where the
final connection
is made i mean these different kind of
levels of networks
there's uh just to talk about some of
those i mean so there is some
uh the internet
where everything has
every device has some address and you
have this whole mechanism for sending
data
uh
that that across the internet and the
most common way that you're interacting
with things across the internet is there
is a server and you are making requests
like you're saying http you're sending a
request that asks for a web page and you
say get me this web page and the server
responds and gives you a whole bunch of
html code that then your browser
responds to that's a typical sort of
transaction on the internet um there's
also uh other kinds of from
networks like for example on a
local wi-fi network
you are uh typically communicating with
the outside internet
through
uh
just by having that be something
where i should should
where you have
the point of the normal point of wi-fi
is it's wireless
um and so you have radio communication
as opposed to sort of the backbone of
the internet which is fiber optic cables
and things like this
um but many of these uh you know pieces
are getting blurred and as 5g networks
come in there'll be more and more things
that are just purely wireless everywhere
so it's kind of i'm not sure that
distinction can really be made but each
one of these different
uh
systems whether it's wi-fi or other
kinds of things
there are definite uh definite ways that
data gets sent through those networks
so wi-fi is one common mechanism another
one is bluetooth
um
the uh these things have different
uh radio frequencies and different
ranges and things like that bluetooth
tends to be uh shorter range i don't
know how far it stretches maybe 10 20
feet
in free space um whereas wi-fi can be
probably a few hundred feet or something
maybe longer than that depends on
whether you have if you have a kind of a
big wi-fi antenna repeater you can get
it to go further and so on and bluetooth
is much
uh lower power and so for example you
can have battery operated devices that
routinely use bluetooth connections many
mice and keyboards and things don't
bother to have wires they just use
bluetooth connections
um bluetooth has um
uh they're different
it's it gets really complicated they're
different kinds of bluetooth connections
um uh ble bluetooth low energy was one
that came in
probably ten years ago now um and that's
used by some kinds of uh devices like uh
you know fitness watches and
things like this
if you look at kind of
what is being sent by bluetooth to
your computer
your computer
can typically be set up to communicate
via bluetooth with a device but your
computer kind of has to
pair with that device it says it's it's
this device it has a certain id and your
computer kind of you have to tell your
computer yes i want your the computer to
be able to send data
um to and from that device
um but that's that's something that um
works that way i mean there are there
are yet different
kinds of of ways to communicate like nfc
which is um
uh the mechanism
where you have um
uh for example with your phone
and is it the same thing with with
credit cards with um
uh the tap credit card mechanism i'm not
sure i think that's the same protocol
i'm not certain of that um but yet again
that's something which is using radio
but it's using radio an incredibly uh
low energy and short range and the funky
thing about um
uh some of these things with you know
tap your credit card is that what's
happening is that an electrical signal
is being that electrical
uh
you're you're you're getting some kind
of circuit in your credit card to
actually do a computation
based on that it's powered by
uh i guess it's effectively powered by
electromagnetic induction
from the thing that you are tapping the
credit card against
and there's a slightly different version
of that which is key fobs
where you have i think they have little
loops of wire in them connected to a
little tiny microprocessor chip um and
uh when you put that near the um the
sort of the door entry thing it's
inducing i think some small voltage in
that little wire enough to power the
circuit the tiny circuit inside the key
fob
um and then it's it's uh
basically the the um
the doors of interrogating the key fob
with uh you know what um with
essentially a small uh piece of
encryption that determines whether this
is really the thing that but what what
the id of that key fob is
um
but anyway i think the the
original question here had to do with
when there are lots of internet of
things devices
will that sort of swamp the whole um
internet i mean i think these days there
are a few billion computers in the world
actually ordinary computers but there
are vastly more kind of uh computer-like
devices and sensors and so on and i
think i think cars like typically have
30 to 50 kind of little computers inside
them in addition to maybe one bigger
computer um
and uh lots of kinds of devices are
starting to have little computers that
possibly are connected to sensors that
measure particular things
um you know is that uh what's the
temperature of that at that particular
in that particular room what's the uh
uh i don't know
lots of uh you know i i
like you know have a little um weather
weather station thing outside that is
just measuring wind speed and
temperature and humidity and things like
that that's another device that's
communicating um through
the network somehow now some of those
devices a pretty common mechanism is to
have those devices communicate through
things like bluetooth
with something like a phone or a
computer which then
sends the data
on to some uh perhaps some server
somewhere across the internet but
sometimes those devices can also
uh communicate directly and sometimes
those devices are directly sort of
plugged in to the internet and then
they're they're sending their
information um however they do i mean so
for example with wolfram language um
which is bundled on the little raspberry
pi computers that cost i know a few tens
of dollars
um the uh you can have a whole wolfram
language running on the raspberry pi
computer and that computer can be
connected to a camera
or whatever else and some processing can
be done locally like it can decide i
know somebody
who made a kind of cat flap dog flap
thing where it uses machine it uses our
image identify function running on a
raspberry pi with a camera to decide
whether the thing that is trying to come
into the house is a cat or a dog and
then
make some decision accordingly um
and i think that's uh so so there's
always this question of do you do
processing do you do that recognition or
is it cat or dog locally on the computer
that's there or do you have to send data
back to some central server which is
going to be the cat versus dog server
and then send it send a message back to
the the
flap to say whether to open or not or
whatever else it was doing
so in any case one of the issues i
suppose is as you start to get
uh sort of lots and lots of devices that
are trying to send data um to
the internet what happens many of these
devices many of these sensors send data
only quite rarely like the cat flat gob
dog flap thing is presumably
well
again this is complicated i mean it is
usually a good idea to try and process
as much as you can locally before you
have to send the data all the way to
some remote computer um because that's
it's um
if you can just have that local computer
just run things you don't have to spend
the effort to send all the data across
the internet or whatever else
when you are sending data
uh
when different devices are operating on
a network and you're sending data from
different devices there's another where
we're kind of submerging into lots of
layers of engineering kinds of uh things
but but um another big story is the
story of qos the quality of service
mechanism
and so the issue is if you have multiple
things that are trying to
connect uh through your for example
let's say you have a um an internet
connection at your house
and you are
and there are multiple things that are
going through that internet connection
you're looking at web pages you're
streaming a video
you're doing avoid phone call you're
doing you know other kinds of things
there's a question of what gets priority
let's say you're also uploading some big
file or downloading some big file what
gets priority on that internet
connection
and so there has to be sort of a pecking
order of things so for example if you
are using
the internet connection through a phone
call
you can really notice if the if the
connection says oops i'm doing something
else now you'll hear a you know
the person the other end will just
freeze or you won't hear anything or
they won't hear you and that's bad on
the other hand if you're uploading or
downloading a file and for just for a
moment the file stops transmitting as
many bytes as it was otherwise it's like
so what it'll catch up and you'll
eventually get the whole file
so that means that the
this qos mechanism that sort of
determines what has priority um you'll
want to prioritize things like the uh
voice over internet voice over ip phone
call to be higher priority than
something like a file transfer because
you really you as a human really notice
the glitch in the phone call you
wouldn't notice such a glitch in the
file transfer so there's a whole world
of sort of optimizing these kinds of
things
and sometimes you can have to adjust
these things by hand to optimize you
know what what are the things that you
as a human notice versus the things you
don't notice and that certainly helps in
terms of some of these devices where it
can matter you know usually there are
two parameters that are important in
network connections throughput and
latency so throughput is just how much
data can you ultimately get through the
network like for example if you're uh
watching a movie
in the end you need to get all the
frames from the movie through you need
to transmit and usually by the way in
the way that streaming services work if
they detect that your network
bandwidth the total amount of data you
can send through the network
every second or something is lower they
will reduce the the quality of the of
the movie they'll reduce the resolution
of the pictures so that you can still
get the you know whatever it is 30
frames a second or whatever the the rate
is that that corresponds to the movie um
because otherwise if you if you stop
getting frames it's like your you know
amazing movie with with uh you know
whatever it is the the uh the you know
the dragon and space or whatever it is
you know the thing will just freeze
there because it didn't get the next
frame yet
but so it's important you know if you're
sending a movie you have to ultimately
get all the bits that are necessary to
see the whole you know dragon in space
or whatever it's doing um
uh to see the movie but it isn't so
important if when you receive
the
uh those frames they could be delayed by
five seconds and you would never know
uh in other words the movie when you
press go on the movie and it says it
waits it buffers up it often says
buffering um
it uh uh it'll
it's it is
it is getting ready so that it will show
you it will be
it doesn't the latency the fact that it
doesn't immediately start playing it
it's waiting it's storing up enough
stuff that's pretty sure that as it goes
on it will always be able to fill to get
enough bits to you that never has to
stop the movie even though the movie
might not be playing the movie as you
see it
for example let's say the movie is of
some event that's happening it could be
that the you know the camera is
photographing the event and if you were
right there you know in the stadium
looking at at your computer or your
phone you would see that actually it's
delayed by five seconds or something
relative to the real life event
um but that latency is not important in
that case when you're just watching the
event uh you know at home or whatever on
the other hand if you're doing a phone
call
and there's a lot of latency it's like
you say hello
and then it's wait wait wait wait for
five seconds and then the person
you know hears your hello and they say
hello
back again and that's super confusing
and doesn't work very well
so in in the case of the so latency is
important in something like um the uh uh
you know a phone call and so typically
there are some trade-offs about how much
latency versus how much throughput um
and uh the different kinds of situations
like for example
if you are sending data to a satellite
um the satellite might be a long way
away and just by virtue of the speed of
light as your radio signal goes the
satellite comes back down again there
might be significant latency but it
might be the case that you can send huge
amounts of data to the satellite so
there might still be high throughput
um and there are other cases where
there is
low
latency but also low throughput that is
you can it's all good you can
immediately get the signal some signal
through and you know what's happening
like for for a keyboard for example
communicating with a computer that
better be low latency or you're going to
have a weird situation where you press a
key and nothing shows up on your
computer screen um but it's not so
important what the throughput is because
you know you know you just don't type
very fast so there's no way that that
can be a problem if the if the network
connection for your keyboard has low
throughput so long as it has low latency
which means it's fast to actually see
the result of the key that's all good
well let's see that was a little bit of
um uh discussion of that
um
let's see
uh
okay pontius is commenting that the
implementation of ipv6
solve the problem of the number of
possible internet addresses yeah i mean
just to explain that when you see an
internet of this so so an address like
wolfen.com
is
the domain name
and uh that domain name has to be
resolved into a raw
address
that is what's used in the tables that
tell a computer how to send a signal
that gets to that server
um and so
that's dns domain name
which is the s stands for
it's a dns is that is the system that
domain name
resolves domain names and turns them
into
um
uh and turns them into these raw ip
addresses and it sometimes very
confusing
that
uh often
locally on some network there will be a
cache of them of those translations
between domain names and um
uh and um
uh ip addresses but sometimes you will
have to go there's a whole hierarchy of
domain name servers
um
in in the world ending up with the what
is it 13 root name servers that
ultimately are the authority on how the
domain name is connected to the ip
address um but uh sometimes when you
think oh i've got an internet connection
this is all good but before you can
actually reach the website you're going
to get to you have to resolve the domain
name you have to go to a dns server and
that's a separate transaction that's a
separate internet like
transaction on the internet but it's not
like a web transaction like going to
fetch data from a website and so
sometimes you'll be in situations i
don't know
happened to me on planes um where
the
where the dna the domain name lookup
just doesn't work
and so uh if you in fact could you could
actually reach a website by going to a
raw ip address
um but you couldn't you can't do that
that look up between the address and the
the raw
the domain name and the raw address so
it used to be the case that uh the
internet was based on ipv4 which is
means what is the address so typical
address is 140.177.10.20
that's a typical ipv4 address um like
140.177 was you know we that's a class b
network that was so networks
uh that they're these different
sort of sizes of networks like the class
a network
bought the addresses that will be like
the the um the
one two seven
no that's a bad example
uh let's say two one one
um
uh that that initial number goes up to
255
um because it is one byte eight bits of
data
um and so uh let's say you've got uh two
one seven or something um
you can have a class a network where you
have all
well where allocated to you and
available for your computers are all the
network addresses that start with 217
and then have all the other
uh all the other bytes after that you
can you can decide how to allocate all
those things
um so it's like class a class b class c
networks
and in the end every computer
uh
has
at least in the past had an ipv4 address
which was of the form that i mentioned
you know
140.177.10.14 or something um
it's a little bit confusing because
there also are local ip addresses that
don't have the same sort of base
um uh sort of base they
the thing i just mentioned the same
structure but a different meaning um
okay the thing i mentioned is for sort
of global internet okay so
a number of years ago
uh everybody realized that that one was
going to run out of addresses
um because the the total number of
addresses is only
um uh 256
probably 255 actually 256 to the fourth
power um which is let's see 2v8
uh
um
right to the
let's see um
it's just 232 is that right i think
that's right
so that allows only if i'm calculating
it right that allows only four billion
devices
and
you can easily run out of that and not
only that it's also not completely
efficiently allocated like for example
we used to have uh
the whole of 140.177
was allocated to our company which would
allow us to have
um a huge number of devices we don't
have as many devices as that so some of
those internet addresses were simply not
allocated
and
okay so what what happened is that was
extended to ipv6 which means that
instead of being four blocks of numbers
four bytes
um there are six
and
there's a whole giant adventure of sort
of moving the internet to have
everything work with ipv6
and it's going kind of slowly as these
sort of changes of standards often do
but in the end this problem of uh you
know running out of internet addresses
will be put off for a long time at least
it depends on what eventually
thinks it needs an internet address but
for the foreseeable future there will be
enough addresses
let's see more things about engineering
let's see
um
okay so there's a question from paul
here as higher frequencies are used in
wi-fi to achieve higher bandwidth wi-fi
range and penetration is reduced is
there tech that would simultaneously
increase both bandwidth and range
yeah so i mean the very common
two gigahertz
which is so so
okay so when you are specifying a radio
signal
you're you're specifying the frequency
of the signal that means the number of
times in terms of an antenna that's
causing the electromagnetic wave to be
produced that means it's kind of how
often the electrons are going back and
forth in that um in that little piece of
uh in the antenna how often the voltage
is being reversed to push the electrons
different ways
to create the electromagnetic wave
how often you get from crest to wave to
trough of wave and so on and
the the wave is at least in in is going
at the speed of light um and so there's
a conversion between
how how fast the the wave is going up
and down
from peak to trough and so on and the
wavelength of the wave that is the
distance between peak and trough
um and uh the the
antenna in a rough approximation an
antenna has to be a length that is
somehow about the
the wavelength of the um of the
radiation of the of the wave
often you have quarter wave antennas and
things like that which are but it's it's
on the order of the wavelength of the um
of the
of the signal
so a pretty common
wavelength was two gigahertz two billion
uh
sort of reversals per second
um and that corresponds to i should know
this it's like i think it's a few
centimeters right
uh wavelength let's work it out
two gigahertz is two times ten to the
nine
uh
uh cycles per second
um and what we want to do
is uh
um
uh it's the
it's the speed of light
divided by that will give us the
wavelength the speed of light is three
times ten to the eight meters per second
so it's 3 times 10 to the 8 divided by 2
times 10 to the 9
which this is where mental arithmetic is
relevant and i'm going to get it wrong
is 1.5 times 10 to the minus 1. so 0.15
meters so that would mean that 2
gigahertz
would be about 0.15 meters or 15
centimeters so is about right of the
frequency
for of the wavelength corresponding to
that frequency so that was a pretty
common cellular
frequency and wi-fi frequency
um there was also for for some internal
stuff i think it was 900 megahertz uh
that's 0.9 gigahertz
um and what's becoming more common is
five gigahertz and even higher
frequencies
and
the
uh
the good news okay so another important
fact
is that if you want to send a signal
then what you're doing roughly when you
send a signal is normally you have this
electromagnetic wave the radio wave but
it's just uh if
at a particular frequency it's just
merely going along peak to trough peak
to trough it's making a sine wave a
perfect sort of regular wave
but if you want to actually send data
then you have to perturb that wave
because the way you're you're encoding
information is by little wiggles on that
wave and there are different ways to put
the wiggles on the wave you can change
the overall amplitude of the wave you
can change the frequency of the wave you
can do more complicated things but
you're basically putting wiggles on this
wave
and the point is that you can't if the
wave itself has a frequency that is
uh the
you in order to
in order to
make
okay so each
wiggle each bit
can't be
at a smaller scale
than
the um
than the rate at which the the wave is
uh is going up and down itself so you
can't you can't send data there's sort
of a limit on how fast you can send data
how much how much you can make a change
in the wave um is you can't make a
change that is
uh
of a
higher frequency than the wave than the
then the basic uh sort of form of the
wave itself and so that means that if
you want to send data at a higher rate
you need a higher frequency of radio
wave to do that
um and you don't get to use the
absolutely full uh
um
full frequency of the wave
this is this is complicated the um
let's not go into that but it's it's you
you well
if you used if you really used sort of
the full frequency you could change the
form of the wave completely and then you
would kind of uh interfere with with
folks who were using a wave of a
different frequency
um so
in any case the higher the frequency
roughly the more data you will be able
to
transmit
uh per
uh
per second or whatever else and so
there's a push to have
higher frequencies used so for example
if you go from radio waves
if you um uh
by the time if you increase the
frequency keep increasing the frequency
you'll get to infrared
uh and then you get to visible light and
then to ultraviolet and so on and so
visible light like a laser that's
sending signals a visible light laser
that's uh sort of um sending you know
now there's laser light now it stops
being laser light now there's laser
light again you can send things at um
the frequency of that is more like
terahertz
um in um actually more than that let's
see that is um
uh now you see i have to do a
calculation again i should know this
cold but i don't um visible light uh
typical frequencies there are things
like 500 nanometers
um which is uh
so that's 500 times 10 minus 9 meters
um and uh five times ten minus
seven meters
somebody's going to tell me i'm getting
all of this wrong but i think five times
n minus seven meters
and that is if we want to find the
frequency
we would uh see we would
take um the speed of light
uh divided by that so three times ten to
the eight meters per second
divided by
five times ten to the minus seven
uh
meters
so that's um
uh
let's the three and the five we're just
going to assume that they sort of cancel
out um
that's uh ten to the eight divided by
ten to minus seven is otherwise ten to
the eight plus ten to the seven plus 10
to the eight plus seven which is um uh
10 to the 15.
so um that's uh
um
it's higher frequency than i thought it
was
hm did i get this calculation right
so terahertz
is still radio waves that's terahertz
radiation is what's used for things like
airport scanners and so on um so maybe
this is right it's um hmm
that's right well that would be uh
uh that would be more like peta hertz
but i've not
um
maybe it's in the hundreds of terahertz
maybe i got a little bit wrong there but
it's it's um so that's so visible light
has higher frequency than any of these
radio waves and so you can send data at
a higher rate using visible light
because it has higher frequency and and
so if you're if you're using visible
light um you could for example uh if
the the um
uh if you're sending it through a fiber
well the fiber reduces its speed a bit
because it's not going quite at the
speed of light but if you're doing it
just through the air it's pretty close
to speed of light in a vacuum um and if
if if you're so you could if you have a
laser and a visible light laser you
could be sending data at a very high
rate by just modulating by changing that
that um uh that that light from the
laser
of course the problem with visible laser
light is
well it's it's all well and good if you
have two devices that have sort of a
line of sight and you could if you look
from one device to the other you could
see that other device because there's
light from that other device reaching
you um then it's all good but as soon as
there's a wall in the way or something
or some other object that doesn't let
light through then that's not going to
work
so a typical thing that happens is
the higher the frequency the more you
the more data you're going to be able to
get uh transmitted but the more you're
going to be stuck with things like oh
there's a wall there um you know the
light doesn't go through the high
frequency radio doesn't go through
either
um as you go to that there are other
effects like diffraction that allows
uh
something
where where it isn't like a laser
beam will be just it goes directly from
here to there whereas for some of these
kinds of uh
there's
when when the thing is acting more like
kind of waves on an ocean except these
electromagnetic waves you can end up
with this phenomenon of diffraction
where the waves will not just go
straight from here to there but they'll
be there they're kind of um they'll be
sort of
once they hit something there'll be a
new wave and it'll be kind of in circles
and and you'll you'll not have to go
straight in a straight line from here to
there and the lower the frequency the
more of that can happen and also
uh many materials
are
they have a different response at
different different radio frequencies
and so some radio frequencies will
happily succeed in getting through the
material of a wall or something and
others will not uh and different kinds
of walls you know if you have a stone
wall that's kind of bad for most radio
frequencies if you have a piece of
drywall i don't know exactly what the
characteristics are but but that's an
easier thing to get through
so one of the issues is um in a
situation where you're using higher and
higher frequencies that's great in terms
of being able to transmit more data it's
bad in the sense that you can't um you
you don't just get to have you know uh
like with
an old-fashioned radio or something or
even modern uh
um
that you can be sort of uh in a room
somewhere deep in a house and somehow
the radio waves will will get to you by
you know they'll they'll get through the
windows and things like that and then
they'll diffract around this thing and
and it
it's it's easier for them to get to you
whereas if they're very high frequency
uh
uh waves it's only going to be uh you
know do you have sort of a direct path
and there's nothing in the way type
thing okay so the number one way that
people expect to deal with that
particularly for things like 5g the sort
of upcoming uh standard for phone uh
phones and other mobile devices um the
main way people expect to deal with that
is by having
by a couple of different things but
basically by having repeaters
where you'll have a device
that um
gets the radio waves the radio waves
come to it and it then re-transmits
those radio waves in different
directions and so even though it's kind
of like you you go from here to there to
somewhere else and it doesn't have to be
a straight line because you get to the
repeater and then the repeater will
transmit something in a completely
different direction now in something
like 5g
there's a lot of cleverness because uh
you are making it so that you're
essentially transmitting often you know
you it knows your phone is in this place
so it tries to transmit the radio signal
as if it was pointed directly as if
somehow the antenna was pointed directly
at your phone
but the thing that can happen is when
you have a big dish antenna one of these
big parabolic antennas that uh you know
you see with radio telescopes and things
like that um that antenna can receive or
transmit
in a particular direction but you have
to turn the antenna and to physically
turn the antenna so that it is oriented
in the direction you want it to transmit
in
there's a kind of a clever method
uh to avoid doing that with a phased
array
um where instead of actually physically
moving anything
all you're doing is you're changing
like like different parts of an antenna
there's an antenna broken into pieces
and different parts of the antenna are
all transmitting a wave but they're
transmitting it um shifted in some way
and that shift is the equivalent of
having the antenna um sort of tipped in
a particular direction and so you can
kind of arrange by by messing around
with sort of exactly the the
when the wave starts in one piece of the
antenna relative to when it starts the
other piece and uh you can kind of um
sort of shape the the wave so that
so that it is effectively um being
transmitted as a beam in a particular
direction and so that's how things like
5g work they have this kind of mechanism
for for arranging to send to effectively
steer the um uh the signal to go in a
particular direction but there's not
nothing physically moving it's it's just
a a pure um
it's based on timing information about
uh when an electrical signal is in this
part of the antenna versus that part of
the antenna and so on and that that's um
uh and in fact 5g has another mechanism
that is it kind of sends out an initial
kind of um what they call pilot waves
i forget what it's called oh gosh what
is it called
pilot wave is either that well that's
the term used in in in a particular
interpretation of quantum mechanics and
it's a it's a confusion okay so anyway
they send out an initial
signal
that um
kind of
uh
and then they
watch kind of how that signal comes back
and that kind of maps out
things like the geometry of the room
you're in and allows it to know
how it can best send signals that will
reach the device that you're trying to
reach and so on it gets pretty
complicated and the another thing that
i'm sort of glossing over there is
what's called multipath effects
where a signal could for example it
might go straight from here to there it
might bounce off a wall or it might go
through
two different possible openings and
there might be multiple paths
that a signal can go from the source of
the signal to the receiver of the signal
and being able to sort of handle all of
those different multiple paths is a
tricky thing and there are lots of uh
lots of work on kind of the best
algorithms to do that
let's see
um
gosh uh
it's questions here from um
ernesto about gravitational waves
and um
uh
traveling through penrose's eons
wouldn't this gravitational wouldn't it
make particles
uh
wiggle the quantum level okay so there's
a i have to take this this apart a
little bit
so first of all let's talk about
gravitational waves
so
uh
gravitational waves are
uh
normally
something like the earth
produces a gravitational field
it is
um and that causes things to fall
towards the earth for example
and the interpretation of that
in the
uh
previous current i would say um
uh the the
sort of the last hundred years
interpretation of that
has been
that
the reason that
there is that that gravity happens is
because the presence of the mass of the
earth
is distorting the structure of
space-time
and is curving
space effectively in such a way that
even though
let's say something is being is going
past the earth even though the thing
that's going past the earth sort of
thinks it's going in the shortest is
going the shortest path
it's not going in a straight line
because the space that it's going
through is curved and so it's deflected
and that deflection
is a is a consequence you can think of
it as a consequence of the fact that the
earth is producing gravity
so whenever there is a um uh
um
uh
the the whenever there's mass
it it distorts the structure of space
and it produces gravity
um
now
when
there's a separate phenomenon which is
once once you're saying that that
gravity is this
deflection this this distortion of space
one of the things that can happen is you
can have waves of distortion
you can have something where the
structure of space is distorted and it
makes something that's kind of like a
you know it's like a water wave except
that that distortion of the surface that
you see on a water wave is in fact
a distortion of the structure of space
and in particular
what what it means to distort the
structure of space is that for example
uh two points that that you sort of
might think with this distance apart if
you kind of let's say you have an object
and you're moving it
and that object sort of has a quotes
fixed length and you move it into
different parts of space
the effective length of that object will
seem to be different in different parts
of space because the sort of the the
actual uh the the measuring stick of
space has changed
so in any case the main things was the
prediction of general relativity um
einstein's theory from 1915 that there
should be gravitational waves um which
is these kind of things that are sort of
distortions of space-time that
move through space
just like a water wave on the surface of
water would move across water just to
make things super confusing in the in
the jargon of physics
there are things in water called gravity
waves that have to do with the the
interaction of gravity with the surface
of water gravity waves and water have
nothing to do with gravitational waves
in space-time except for the fact that
they have somewhat similar names um but
in any case
the um
in space
uh it is a necessary consequence
of
the the general relativity theory of
gravity that there will be gravitational
waves and that there will be these
propagating distortions in space-time
and for a long time these were kind of a
theoretical thing and then about five
six years ago uh gravitational waves
were detected as
two big detectors one in louisiana one
in washington state
and how do you detect them well you
basically detect gravitational waves
because
the the length of things will change
when the gravitational wave comes
through because effectively one is
changing the structure of space and
one's changing it every time the you
know the gravitational wave is coming
through and and it is
effectively changing the length of an
object so these these um devices have
these kind of long arms of i don't know
how long is it it's like a mile maybe
i'm forgetting i've seen it but i've
only seen the outside of the tunnel um
maybe it's maybe let's say it's a mile
long and you're measuring the effective
length of this mile long thing
as the gravitational wave comes through
that length is changed because the the
the effective length has changed because
essentially the measuring stick of of
the of of the structure of space is
changed
and in order to detect this you're using
using basically light bouncing back and
forth down this arm and you're looking
at very tiny changes
in the way in which interference of
light works as a result of the length of
this arm changing so that's how you
detect a gravitational wave and it's a
little tricky because
uh
well gravitational waves
um
the deformation associated with
gravitational waves is always what's
called the quadrupole deformation so
it isn't when i'm telling you it's just
changing the length of something it's
not quite the right story it's it's like
squashing a thing in one direction and
pulling it out in the in the uh
in the orthogonal direction in the
opposite direction so it's like you're
pushing in and pulling out
and that's
gravitational waves that's what they do
is they they make these quadrupole
deformations that uh push out in one
direction and pull in the other
direction
so
okay what's the analogy between so
electromagnetic waves
are
uh
something that um
uh
they they have many characteristics the
same
they i i should say gravitational waves
uh go at the speed of light and it's
even been measured they seem to go
pretty accurately at the speed of light
um
and
they
uh when electromagnetic waves
are like radio for example are produced
when you accelerate an electric charge
um when you are moving an electric
charge it's going up it's going down
it's going in an antenna you have a
voltage it's pushing the electric
electrons up and down you move those
electrons as electric charges you move
them you accelerate them you first push
them to go up then you turn around they
make them go down that ex repeated
acceleration produces an electromagnetic
wave it's the same thing with gravity
that accelerating charges accelerating
masses produce gravitational waves
and even a
a a star that's a planet that's being
kept in orbit around the star if it's
binary star one star is orbiting around
the other or they're orbiting around
their their common center of mass
then then that
the fact that you are you're continually
accelerating the thing to keep it in
orbit to keep it going in a circle
otherwise would just go in a straight
line if you didn't if you didn't
exert a force keep it accelerated and so
on um even that produces gravitational
waves but the most intense gravitational
waves that are produced are by pairs of
black holes
that spiral in and are going uh they're
they're they're heavy they're fast
and um uh that and they produce uh
intense gravitational waves um because
uh
um and they do so particularly as they
spiral in and eventually two black holes
will merge as they spiral in they go
faster and faster and they produce more
and more intense gravitational waves and
the the final moments of inspiring of of
black holes um final maybe five seconds
or something that produce very intense
gravitational waves intense enough the
detectors we have will detect a merger
of two black holes
in spiraling the black holes pretty much
all the way across the universe at this
point
um and they happen oh how often is it
every few days one of those black hole
mergers is happening somewhere in the
universe and is detectable and they're
are gravitational waves that we receive
from those things
um
and and and the the final moment is this
uh you know about five seconds or so of
of kind of you see these these um uh you
see kind of a signal in the
gravitational waves
of the um
it kind of
goes up and down in intensity um and
then eventually disappears as as the
black hole kind of merges into one
and and there are
in fact uh even in our models we can we
can looks like we can reproduce that
that kind of ring down that that effect
of the of the inspiring black holes and
then the the kind of um once the once
the final single black hole is formed it
kind of blobbles around like a bell um
and eventually becomes a nice spherical
black hole but as it as it rings down um
it still emits gravitational waves so
okay so that's sort of the story of
gravitational waves as they come from
things like black hole mergers
now
it's also the case
let's see how to explain this
um
okay so electromagnetic radiation
produced by accelerating charges we can
sort of do it on demand when we make
radio and things like that
when
you just have something that's hot
you have a bunch of electrons and atoms
and things whizzing around because
that's what heat is is these atoms
moving around and so on and you end up
with the same kind of phenomenon that
you've got these charges moving around
all that kind of thing you're going to
produce
the right way to explain it yeah that's
an okay way to explain it um you're
going to produce a certain amount of
electromagnetic radiation
anything that's hot
is going to produce certain amount of
electromagnetic radiation things glow
red hot then white hot then blue hot and
so on um that's producing different
frequencies of electromagnetic different
peaks in the in the in the spectrum of
virtual magnetic radiation from things
that are peaked in the red uh part of
the spectrum which is lower frequency
than things which are spread across the
visible spectrum so it's white then
things that are kind of zooming off into
the ultraviolet so you the part that's
visible is just the blue part but higher
frequency anyway so you get what's
called black body radiation
um which is radiation that is produced
by as a result of uh
let's say heat
and then
that you can kind of have distant well
okay so so things
i'm trying to think what the best way to
explain this is because i'm about to
about to run into a bump in this
explanation but in any case the the the
um uh
when you
when you just have
you you can you just have uh
electromagnetic radiation where it's
sort of there are uh there are photons
that are going that there's an
ultromagnetic radiation that's kind of
in some let's say cavity where the walls
of the cavity are hot
and you're just getting um uh there's
just a bunch of electromagnetic
radiation inside and the hotter the
walls the the change of the spectrum
radiation in fact in 1900 a guy called
max planck uh studied the experiments on
um
on that black body radiation on the
spectrum of black body radiation
and that's how
he ended up concluding that there must
be discrete quanta of electromagnetic
radiation in order to account for the
distribution of that spectrum and that's
what eventually led particularly through
einstein's work to the idea of photons
particles of light and so on but any
case when there's when things are hot
you'll have a
black body radiation electromagnetic
radiation
you also have other kinds of radiation
so we also have
gravitational radiation
um you also have and that's something
which you know think of all those little
things you know if you have something
hot and things are moving around and
they're accelerating and so on they're
going to produce gravitational radiation
too
and so there is
the sort of most dramatic version of
that is the cosmic microwave background
which is a black body radiation that is
left over from when the universe was
very hot in the very early stages of the
universe and
the bump that i was watching myself run
into
is explaining the fact that it's a
little bit different when you have a
cavity that has walls and things are are
producing uh and you have sort of
temperature because things are sort of
whizzing around inside the walls
producing electromagnetic radiation that
way and what happened in the other
universe
where
sort of uh
in a sense the the um uh every particle
there was um uh had a certain
um
was was moving around with a certain
energy and that's kind of the way that
uh that that leads to this black body
radiation but basically what happened is
in the early universe
um every
possible
kind of
radiation like that
had to exist when the universe was hot
enough the universe when it was
sufficiently young
was very hot very high temperature
things were moving around very rapidly
as it got bigger the temperature goes
down um and uh
at this
at this stage of the universe
the photon
the electromagnetic background radiation
is at 2.7 degrees above absolute zero
2.7 kelvins that's minus 270 i can't do
that uh
260
oh my gosh
um 266 minus 266 degrees centigrade
would be the uh effective temperature
did i get that right
no minus 270 um
degrees centigrade will be the effective
temperature of
the
uh
of the photons
in
uh throughout the universe right now
now
trickily enough
the um
uh the temperature so there are other
forms of background radiation
in the universe there's there's
electromagnetic background radiation at
2.7 kelvins there's also neutrino
background radiation neutrinos
are very light almost zero mass
particles that interact very weakly
neutrino background radiation is about
1.9 kelvins
and there's also gravitational
background radiation which is presumably
at a much lower temperature
the reason for these differences of
temperature is because
these um
different
kinds of radiation
well
as the universe
as as the things
sort of the heat in the universe
okay everything in the universe is hot
but
gradually some things decouple from the
things that are hot so what do i mean by
this so for example in the case of
electromagnetic radiation
um when the universe was above
what is it
let's say 10 000 degrees centigrade but
that's not exactly right it's something
of that order but that's not it's not
exactly that
um was above some number of thousands of
degrees centigrade um
the the atoms
in the universe will be will have been
uh the electrons in the world been
stripped away and that means that you
have something that's kind of like fire
or plasma you'll have something where
photons don't get through there it's
it's opaque to visible light
um but at some moment as the universe
cools down
atoms will form it's so-called
recombination atoms i don't know why
it's called recombination because the
things were always uncombined before
that in the in the um in the history of
the universe but but at that moment
about a hundred thousand years after the
beginning of the universe
um things cool down to the point where
the electrons can get stuck in atoms and
you have ordinary neutral things like
hydrogen atoms and at that point the
universe becomes effectively transparent
to things like uh to electromagnetic
radiation
um and so from that point on
for a photon that was created earlier
than that a photon can just merrily uh
keep moving across the universe after
that and it doesn't expect to hit
anything and eventually it might hit the
detector that we have that detects the
2.7 kelvin um uh cosmic microwave
background
but
that moment of decoupling that happens
maybe a hundred thousand years after the
beginning of the universe
um the the the um the temperature that
the uh the photons get to is determined
by when that happens so the neutrinos
they decouple about one second after the
beginning of the universe
and they have a
and that means that
uh
oh boy this is complicated the expansion
of the universe has caused the
temperature that these things had at the
moment of decoupling to be shifted and
in the case of neutrinos they'd be
shifted down to 1.9 kelvins so in the
case of gravitational waves there should
be a background of gravitational waves
from the early universe um what its
temperature is i'm not sure but it will
have decoupled much earlier in the
history of the universe i think
um and therefore have a lower
temperature
um and that
uh
it's all a bit obscure what you mean by
temperature for something like a
gravitational wave and and there's a
little bit more to explain to really say
exactly what that means
um but roughly it's sort of the
the energy associated with gravitational
waves
so
question i think had to do with a model
of the universe in which um
uh
the um
in which we have the universe it's
expanded maybe it expands to a point and
then the gravity of the things in the
universe
pull on the expanding universe so much
that the universe can't expand anymore
it kind of turns around it starts
contracting again and then there's a big
crunch
as everything is pulled back together
everything that had expanded out is now
pulled back together big crunch
when there's a big crunch everything
comes back together in this crunch and
then it crunches so hard that it
explodes again and starts expanding
again this is a conceivable model
probably not what really is happening a
conceivable model for the long time
history of the universe but it's a
series of these eons where it will be
expanding for a while contract expand
contract expand
and the big question is does anything
survive the big crunch
is there any uh sort of information that
can uh get through that moment when the
universe has has crunched down before it
starts expanding again i have to say i
haven't really thought about this but i
think in our models of physics now
um in our
model of physics based on
discrete structural space and so on that
we've developed in the last few years
i suspect that question can be answered
of what survives or what can survive and
i think the answer
uh let me think about that for a second
um
so that the microscopic structure of
space probably there will be echoes
of previous eons
that conceivably you could reconstruct
from the microscopic structure of space
but let me tell you why that's hard
so
let's say
you are
oh i don't know you've got some
um
you've got an ice sculpture
and um
it's a terrific ice sculpture and it's
in the shape of a lion or whatever else
it is
and then somebody comes along with a
with a thing that really heats it up and
the ice sculpture just turns into steam
okay
it is still the case that in all the
detailed motions of the molecules
let's say it's in a it's in a container
a nice container where you you've the
molecules when they whenever they hit
the walls of the container it'll bounce
off and things like that
as you heat up your your ice sculpture
lion
um eventually it turns into steam but
every molecule from the ice sculpture
lion has a very particular place that's
determined by the fact that this
molecule was from the pore of the lime
but now it's steam and so that molecule
is bouncing across the container hitting
a wall bouncing again and bouncing
bouncing bouncing all over the place and
you know when you look inside this
container it says i've just got a bunch
of steam in this container but if you
looked in incredible detail you would
realize that the particular motions of
molecules that are in that steam were
ones that uniquely were the right ones
to eventually have come from the ice
sculpture line
so in a sense the information of the ice
sculpture lion is still present in the
detailed motions of these molecules just
really hard to extract because you have
to you have to identify what are all
these molecules and which one did that
and oh that collided with this let's
back up the information of that it is
something which is computationally uh
completely infeasible to do
it's a phenomenon that the fact that
that's infeasible is a result of this
phenomenon that i call computational
irreducibility
but in principle if you were to allow
yourself to be a sufficiently
sophisticated computational being with
sufficiently good sensors that could
measure all these molecules in principle
you could say
you see steam i see the result of a of a
lion ice sculpture
and so it will be
with the uh uh the sort of the big
crunch in the universe
um what somebody might say all i see
is a crunch together sort of microscopic
structure of space
somebody else might say but actually
i can if i do this reconstruction
back again i could realize that that
crunch together thing is the result of
some giant civilization that managed to
figure out how to make starships and all
kinds of things like that and yes it all
ended up in this in this crunch down in
this little little tiny effects and the
structure of space um that are not what
has been set up for an observer like us
who has who's looking only at the
large-scale structure of space and so on
there's nothing there just like there's
nothing there in the steam that came
from the lion ice sculpture it just
looks like a bunch of gas molecules
bouncing around but really if you could
decode that you would see that it came
from something something remarkable
now having said that i i do wonder a
little bit in our models of physics
there is a total information content of
the universe
that is determined by the actual number
of atoms of space in the universe and
that number of atoms of space can change
over time and if you simply don't have
enough atoms of space in the universe
you simply don't get to no you don't get
to record
more information just like if you
well actually the gas molecules analogy
is a little different because with gas
molecules in the usual way of thinking
about it you can have a precise velocity
of a gas molecule and that precise
velocity specified to you know 100
digits of precision or something could
give you which is probably not realistic
to actually do but in theory you could
do that and it would give you a huge
amount of information and that nothing
like that will work
in the case of of um if if you're
dealing with a discrete collection of
atoms of space if you've only got
a trillion trillion trillion atoms of
space
then i'm sorry you can't encode uh you
know
all of the knowledge of the galaxy type
thing it just doesn't fit in what you
can encode in a chilean challenge
trolling atoms of space
so there might be some different
limitations there um but when just the
fact that you've crushed all matter down
to something which is essentially just
gravitational waves
a version of just saying it's all just
the structure of space
um
is is not really a thing now i have to
say in our models of physics
everything is just a feature of the
structure of space and so things like
particles like electrons and so on they
are just
detailed
features local features of the structure
of space just like in a fluid like water
or something uh you could have vortices
you know little eddies going around or
or in in the atmosphere you can have you
know hurrica you can have hurricanes
tornadoes things like this those are all
you know what is a tornado made of it's
made of air but nevertheless there's a
definite structure to the tornado and
the tornado can move around and do all
the things tornadoes do but it's
ultimately made of air and so similarly
what we are pretty sure is true is that
things like electrons and all the
particles that we're made of photons all
these kinds of things are ultimately
just made of space in the same kind of
way that tornado is made of air um and
so
this question of whether
when you have deconstructed everything
where there are no particles left
anymore and all you have is features of
space you've still got the same raw
material that you made particles out of
it's just that the space has been so
ground down that you no longer can
identify oh look there's an electron
there just like you you might you you
might not be able to say in the air oh
there's a you know this thing here is
the beginnings of a tornado or something
you just can't can't tell that that it's
there so that that's um a version of
that
um
let's see
well
there's a question here from edgy how do
we still see radiation from the other
universe
um
okay so
uh this is a this is a very confusing
thing it's a little bit of a geometry
exercise okay so
um
when we point a telescope out into space
into the sky
we may see a galaxy far away
and
we know that galaxy is uh
let's say a hundred million light years
away
that means that light
that we are receiving now
from that galaxy
really started from that galaxy 100
million years ago took 100 million years
for light from that galaxy to reach us
here
now
uh
the and
so the question is
let's say there is something from the
early universe so the universe is about
14.6 billion years old let's say there's
light that started its journey
a hundred thousand years after the
beginning of the universe as lots of
light did
and the question is where do we see that
what where do we point our telescope to
see light that started its journey that
long ago
and the answer is we can point it in any
direction we want
because the way
the geometry works it's kind of like
it's it's as if we see the beginning
as i mentioned
the galaxy 100 million years ago
you know as a galaxy in that direction
light started 100 million years ago
another galaxy
in slightly different direction maybe
light started 200 million years ago
um
and
as we look
deeper and deeper as we sort of focus
our
telescope we just look in different
directions and we'll see galaxies that
start where the light started 200
million years ago 300 million years ago
whatever
um
but
uh and let's see those galaxies
how to explain this this is always a a
little bit of a geometrical
uh
brain twister but essentially what
what's true is that that the
in any direction you point your
telescope
you will see light that comes from the
beginning of the universe
in some cases there will be things in
the way
that are where the light originated
there much more recently than the
beginning of the universe
but it doesn't matter in which direction
you point your telescope um
you know focusing far enough away the
things that that that it will correspond
to light that started at the beginning
of the universe
now
why is this why does it work that way
it's because of geometry of thinking
about you you can sort of understand
this better if you think about the whole
sort of space-time geometry of the
universe not just looking at things far
away in space but also dealing with
the
uh
time in the universe and the fact that
uh you
are seeing
light cones you're seeing let's think
how to say this uh
um
well
but the basic idea is that
a
photon
that
this is always very confusing
let's see
um
let's imagine
yeah i mean the the end result is
that you get to see the early universe
uh the only way you would not see
something from the other universe as if
there was a galaxy in every direction
you look and actually that's kind of a
mysterious thing in the universe
that it's
called alba's paradox
the fact that the sky is not bright
because you might think if there were
enough galaxies and if the universe was
old enough that you could um
uh
the um
uh
that
in every if there were galaxies far
enough and far enough back then in every
direction you look you might see a
galaxy because sometime there will have
been a galaxy in that direction
but we don't see that um and that's
partly a consequence the fact that the
universe is not infinitely old
and there are many directions we look we
don't see any galaxies at all
and um and in those directions we are
seeing back to earlier times in the
universe before the formation of
galaxies and so on we're seeing back to
the things that were at the very
beginning of the universe you notice
parker here is suggesting the analogy of
a balloon expanding yes i was thinking
about that analogy that is sort of a
standard analogy that's used and as i
was thinking about it
that analogy wasn't making a lot of
sense to me
um
the uh
a a common kind of way of thinking about
the way the universe works
in terms of its expansion
is that the um uh that imagine you had
the surface of a balloon you had a bunch
of points on the sense of a balloon you
blow the balloon up and all these points
all move further away from each other
now by the way a confusing thing about
the expansion of the universe
is that not everything in the universe
expands
like we don't expand
we are still our meter whatever tall
and will continue to be that height and
it's not the case that we expand our
galaxy doesn't expand
but a galaxy that is far away from us
is moving away from us as a result of
the expansion of the universe much like
these things on the balloon
and the the kind of the rule is if if
the if if the thing that you're looking
at
is gravitationally bound to the thing
the the thing you're you're in so for
example if you have two galaxies and
they're orbiting around each other
they're kind of like there's gravity
pulling these galaxies together if
there's that kind of gravity pulling
these galaxies together then you won't
see them expand but if the galaxies are
kind of so far apart there's no gravity
pulling them together then the
essentially force of expansion of the
universe will cause those uh those
galaxies to be pulled apart it's called
the hubble flow after edwin hubble who
discovered the expansion of the universe
uh experimentally um in the 1910
19 uh 1920s actually yeah
uh
the um and so
that the hubble flow is like a small
force on everything that's pulling
things further apart but when things
have other forces that hold them
together it's a very very tiny force and
it doesn't cause things to go apart but
that's the thing that is kind of
reflecting the overall expansion of the
universe
well okay i should probably um
uh
um
oh boy
a lot of interesting physics questions
here there's one from david here is it
theoretically possible to detect
individual gravitons by launching space
probes into black holes
um
um
i don't see an obvious way to do that
so
just like
electromagnetic waves radio waves things
like that they behave like waves
electromagnetic radiation in general can
be both thought about in terms of waves
and in terms of particles photons in the
case of electromagnetic radiation
in the case of gravitational waves the
same thing is true if you think about
them as waves or presumably you can
think about them also as gravitons
that is uh sort of particles of
gravitational radiation
now
i have to say that
in our
theory of physics
i actually haven't thought about this
it's actually somewhat interesting to
think about what the structure of
gravitons is in our theory of physics
because we understand how
gravity can occur from sort of large
scale features of the structure of space
and we understand how particles like
electrons can exist like kind of
vortices in the structure of space
but when you ask about gravitons
it's an interesting question because
it is
in a sense
you can always think of you know when
you have an electromagnetic field you
can always say oh i'm going to think of
that field as a collection of photons
there's one photon here one photon there
one photon there you can decompose the
electromagnetic field into a collection
of modes that correspond to photons
you can say this field can be thought of
as a photon going in this direction with
this energy photon going in that
direction with that energy et cetera et
cetera you can you can make it up as a
sort of sum of photons
and i suppose the same should be true of
a gravitational field even in our models
but it's actually an interesting
question how that really would work it's
a good question should pin that as a as
a thing for somebody to study at our
upcoming summer school
um
so in terms of the detection of
gravitons
uh
the
the main thing that one can expect to
detect in our models of physics
is the fact that space is discrete
you know if you say
i've got some water it seems continuous
but actually it's made of molecules how
do you detect that it's made of
individual molecules one of the first
ways was detected was through brownian
motion
uh you put a chap called brown
uh who knows what it was actually in but
somebody put little pollen grains
on the surface of water and could see
that they were very the pollen grains
didn't weigh very much and so didn't
take much to kick them around and
individual molecules hitting the pollen
grains kicked the pollen grains you can
see kind of discrete motion of the
pollen grains and that kind of is a clue
that water is not really continuous it's
made of discrete things and so one can
imagine a similar kind of phenomenon
with a structure of space
of what can you have that is a very
sensitive probe of the structure of
space and sort of kicked around by the
discreteness of the structure of space
and there may be things associated with
uh rapidly rotating black holes and so
on that have that uh characteristic
i i don't think i don't immediately see
a way
see the problem is around a black hole
it's very calm when a spacecraft falls
into a black hole the actual moment of
falling through the event horizon after
which the spacecraft can no longer send
light signals that escape the
gravitational field of the black hole
that actual moment of falling through
the event horizon as far as the
spacecraft is concerned is a very calm
moment
nothing dramatic locally happens
it's just that those signals that the
spacecraft might have been able to send
to the outside world they'll get weaker
and weaker and weaker and eventually
bump their no longer can't can't reach
the outside world but there's nothing
sort of dramatic that happens that's
sensitive to the microscopic structure
of the gravitational field that's there
um
so anyway i don't i don't quite see how
that would work
um
and uh okay we've got lots of other
questions here which i think we're going
to have to leave to another time
but all right so we went today from
talking about
wi-fi and a bunch of engineering details
of 5g telephony and so on to talking
about gravitational waves and gravitons
in the structure of space
um i suppose the thing that might bring
them together is will we ever signal
using gravitational waves
you know one of the things that's a
common sort of idea of science fiction
is you know actually there's an
intergalactic
internet out there
but it's using
uh signals of type x
in that intergalactic internet and it's
kind of like as soon as you
manage to send and receive those signals
you're in the club and you get to
communicate with all the inter you know
intergalactic aliens so to speak and
people thought that you know 100 and
something years ago when radio was new
they thought oh gosh we've got radio
signals and we can kind of detect
there's some weird radio signals that
come from the ionosphere um of around
the earth and um uh people sort of heard
those radio signals and were like that
must be signaling from the martians i
think nikola tesla was quite
enthusiastic about that idea
um and um uh you know now that we have
radio now that we're in
you know the the end of the 1800s and
we've invented discovered radio
now we're going to be it's going to be a
kind of intergalactic civilization we're
part of the club of course it didn't
happen that way and those radio signals
weren't
anybody's ordinary definition of an
intergalactic civilization one can
differ on whether one thinks that
there's sort of uh uh that the
ionosphere has kind of a mind of its own
but it isn't what we usually would think
of as sort of a a separate civilization
but um so people then wonder oh if you
look at laser signals for example
flashes of light
you know going across the galaxy of you
know signaling from here to there um
maybe there would be some sort of
extraterrestrial intergalactic signaling
in laser pulses people look for those
and then maybe well maybe that's not it
maybe it's neutrinos maybe there are
people sending you know all kinds of uh
great you know
great forms of literature in you know in
in extraterrestrial alien languages so
to speak across the galaxy all encoded
in neutrino signals or maybe it's
gravitational waves
i don't think it's any of these things i
don't think that's the right idea for
how to think about sort of alien
intelligences but it's kind of an
amusing sort of science fictiony thing
to think about as soon as we have good
enough gravitational wave detectors
we'll discover somebody sending an
encyclopedia in gravitational waves i
doubt it but um it's an amusing thing to
imagine
and uh it's kind of a a thing where
where we can kind of say what are the
different forms of signal that can go
across the universe and it's basically
things that are typically particles of
zero mass like photons and gravitons
that go at the speed of light and that
don't get absorbed too much by other
kinds of things that exist in the
universe those are sort of our
candidates for things that can be used
to signal across the universe
although
radio does pretty well and doesn't get
absorbed much as you go you can have a
radio signal that will go all the way
across the universe or
electromagnetic signal goes all the way
across the universe
all right well we should wrap up there
um
thanks for joining me and
see you another week